all right let's uh move on nancy pelosi
was asked yesterday about this irs plan
which you've heard about on this show
because we've been talking about it uh
the the small little issue of the
vitamin administration trying to remove
and erase our financial um
freedom and privacy altogether by
monitoring all of our bank accounts
almost all of our bank accounts it would
be something like 100 million bank
accounts they'd be monitoring uh that
have transactions of over 600
nancy pelosi was asked about it at press
conference here's what she said
one of the pay fors in the buildback
better bill that's been proposed is irs
cracking down on some unpaid taxes banks
are starting to get calls from customers
and they're reporting these calls
they're concerned about this tracking of
paint of transactions that is greater
than six hundred dollars um so americans
are starting to worry about this do you
think that this paid for of of giving
the irs more money to crack down on
unpleased taxes
is going to stay in the reconciliation
yes
yes
yes yes well i i mean with all due
respect uh the plural of anecdote is not
data i've said that before here yes
there are concerns that some people have
but if people are breaking the law and
not paying their taxes one way to track
them is through the banking measure i
think 600 but that's a negotiation
that will go on as to what the amount is
but yes
600 so it's part of the negotiation but
she she thinks we need to find the high
income earners who are not paying their
taxes
and uh 600 is negotiation maybe it'll be
700
we're looking for the high income
earners so we're going to start in the
hundreds of dollars which again that's
100 million i think that's the number
that i saw
100 million households would be affected
by this
that's
100 million is that uh that's still the
top one percent 100 million
how many people are in this country
billions
no what's actually happening here who
here is who is really being targeted
and and this is who they they're they
really must be looking for because if
they were actually looking
for the billionaires
then they would be
they'd be setting the threshold at
transactions of 60 000
in a month or something like that
um
but they're not and there's a reason for
that
and the real reason is that this is
their excuse to put the almost the
entire country under a permanent irs
audit
and to be able to track you know
everything we're doing all the money
that's coming in and out of our accounts
that's the real reason but who are they
actually going to be finding i mean uh
who are the the so-called tax cheats
that
they're going to be primarily
um exposing here well it's it's going to
be people in the you know in the in the
in the so-called gig economy right
waiters
um
landscapers
you know people who mow lawns
babysitters
it's going to be people like that
very much middle class
uh income wise lower middle class people
who get you know they they a lot of
times they get paid under the table
they make a lot of money off the table
they don't they don't always declare
they get paid in cash they deposit it
doesn't always show up you know there's
not a there's not a w-2
for it
and um they're not always declaring it
as you know 1099 income and all that
kind of stuff
those are the people that are being
targeted
that's what they're fighting they're not
they're not
they're not finding bill gates here
that's not who they're gonna be bringing
to justice they're bringing your
babysitter to justice here that's what
they're doing
which brings me my next question which
is
where are the republicans on this
but i've heard
a few republicans speaking out
but how are they not all in one voice
crying out against this how is this not
the subject of immense
outrage
how is this not at least a subject of of
discussion even on the right
you know this is one of those issues
where i kind of feel like just like with
the sexual abuse epidemic in schools i
felt like i was talking to a brick wall
for years i kind of feel the same way
here
i mean i can't be the only one who sees
this as a big big deal the vaccine
mandates are a big deal that's horrible
this is worse than that
okay we don't need to get into ranking
which is worse in terms of tyranny but
this is worse
this is the irs accessing your bank
account
without a warrant permanently
and republicans are just off twiddling
their thumbs
yeah
they'll monitor the situation just like
the irs will be monitoring our bank
account soon enough they're going to
monitor the situation and uh
you know once this policy is actually in
place then maybe they'll hold a hearing
about i think that's what they're
waiting for wait for the policy to be in
place and then they'll speak up against
it when there's nothing that can be done
about it
wait for the policy to be in place and
then when uh when
you know they run when during a
presidential election then the
republican president can campaign
against it
so that's what's gonna happen this
policy will be put in place
but um republicans won't really start
speaking out against it until you know
late 2023.
[Music]
right in time for the presidential
election
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends